these migrant camps are the last stop
for people planning to get to Britain
the deals are done here between people
Smugglers who have boats and migrants
willing to pay thousands of pounds for a
place on board and overloaded dinghy
we met these men Indians from Punjab
last night they were also out in the
channel their boat started sinking five
kilometers from the French Coast
you went back to France you came to the
beach again on your boat yes we again
again meet then jump and swimming then
swimming yeah very cold water
wow you had to swim yeah back to the
beach yeah
you are lucky to be alive I killed last
night
you die you think you died right yeah
you are lucky that you are here yeah
it is a complex problem look at this
last month we filmed migrants running
past French policing clambering into
boats held offshore by people's
Smugglers the French officers are under
orders not to enter the water
so if you get past them then they can't
stop you
and this year a record number of
migrants have taken to small boats
the channel today was deadly cold
what's remarkable is not that people
died here but that sent off in flimsy
dinghies more people haven't perished in
these waters before
both the French and British say they
will do more to combat this sort of
cross-channel migration
with this rescue and Recovery operation
started in the small hours and it's been
going on all day ever since it involves
both British and French resources now
this French boat has only just been
assigned to work full time here in the
English Channel a sign of a greater
focus by France on cross-channel
migration
while we were out another sign at the
heightened tension
you know
so the Coast Guard coordinating the
British Coast Guard issuing an alert
after reports of more people in the
water
but so far nothing has stemmed the tide
more people arrive or try to cross
despite the peril more debts feel
inevitable